hi everyone in this video we'll talk
about
food and immunity you might have heard
that xyz
supplement or food can boost your
immunity
these kind of information is flooding
the internet
but do you really know the cellular and
molecular mechanism
by which several food can boost your
immunity
do you know the science behind it if you
want to know that then this video is for
you
stay tuned till the end of this video
and you would get some clarity
so starting with the food items that can
possibly boost your immunity
current clinical research and
pre-clinical research suggest
that food items which are enriched in
vitamin a
vitamin d vitamin e c
and zinc can boost your immune responses
in a moment it would be clear that how
these individual
nutrients can possibly augment your
immune response
or can possibly modulate your immune
response along with these vital items
recently it is known that omega-3 fatty
acids
have pla are playing significant role in
terms of immune modulation
we'll learn about all of these things in
this video
okay but before we start we should
really nullify one misconception
there is no one-to-one correlation
between a food item
and immunity for example let's say
citrus fruit like orange contains
vitamin c
don't think that only consuming citrus
food in a large
quantity would help you to fight all
these pathogens
these kind of one-to-one correlation is
not true
things are far more complicated and a
balanced proportion is required
so let me give you an idea
you need a overall balanced diet
to improve your immunity so this
balanced diet would contain
all the necessary items that your immune
system
need to thrive so all these
important items would modify
your metabolism and thereby change your
immune status
and that would help you to fight and
convert the pathogens
now if we talk a little bit in details
we would understand that first criteria
is to take good food or balanced diet
but food is not the only criteria
for boosting the immunity food along
with
several other criteria is required to
boost the immunity
food alone cannot boost the immunity if
you have a lot of stress
or lifestyle problems there right
so food along with subsequent amount of
fluid in your body adequate amount of
sleep
your stress level and ignoring bad
habits
all of these combination can work
together
to boost your immune response let's say
if you have
bad habits and you are taking some good
amount of food and good balance diet
that does not ensure that you would have
a
boosted immune system so a fact
all of these factors would really
be important for your immune system to
function properly
now let me give you some specific
example for your better understanding
arginine is one of the amino acids that
we get from protein diet
and this is very important for immune
function
how is that because one of our
surveillance cell which is known as
macrophages which is a
key cell type in the inner immune
response requires
this amino acid from arginine
macrophage produce reactive nitrogen
species
which is crucial for them to fight
against pathogens
they destroy pathogens with the help of
reactive oxygen and reactive nitrogen
species
so production of reactive nitrogen
species is crucial for them
and arginine is the amino acid which is
the substrate for
making reactive nitrogen species that
means
you need to have sufficient amount of
protein
in your diet right now here is the
misconception
so just because you get arginine from
your protein diet
you might think okay let's eat a lot of
meat steaks and red meat
yes you would get adequate amount of
arginine
but there are other problems first of
all you're in taking a lot of calories
and more you intake red meat you are
tipping the balance between omega-3 and
omega-6 fatty acids
now let me tell you what are they if you
want to know more about omega-3 and
omega-6
you can click on the link in the i
button to learn more about it
now we ideally need
more omega-3s than omega-6 and this
balance is very important because once
omega-6s are more it can increase the
chances of inflammation
because the inflammatory mediator known
as prostaglandin is
generally synthesized from omega-6 fatty
acid
namely arachidonic acid
so we need to have a diet
where omega-3 is more generally
diet in mediterranean countries have
more
omega-3 compared to omega-6 now our diet
in
india is more like western diet which is
more oily stuff
and it is enriched in omega-6 compared
to omega-3 fatty acids
and that is not good now
omega-3 fatty acid inhibits
prostaglandin synthesis by blocking a
crucial enzyme in this process whereas
omega-6
fatty acid augments that that means
a balance between omega-6 and omega-3 is
absolutely essential and we evolve like
this
billions of years ago in prehistoric era
the consumption of omega-6 and omega-3
was in one to one ratio
now around 1900s
this ratio is now tipped to 10 is to 1
more omega 6 consumption and in 2021
it is 20 is to 1 we have
more omega 6 in our diet than omega 3
and this altered balance is causing
many problems including poor immunity
heart diseases and many more so
omega-3 and omega-6 balance should be
always one is to one that's the target
and that's how we evolved so let's come
to the moral of the story because this
is important
so we need to include a lot of walnut
salmon
tuna chia or flax seed in our diet
and we should avoid eating too much of
red meat
processed food and all these other items
that are enriched in omega-6 fatty acid
now comes vitamin e vitamin e
is one of the most important antioxidant
in our body vitamin e can be obtained
from various sources before the sources
i'll tell you how vitamin e modulates
our immune system
it modulates both adaptive and the
inner arm of the immune system so
dendritic cell macrophages
t cells b cells and nk cells all are
modulated
with the help of vitamin e now
there are several molecules which are
crucial for
all of these cell type functions are
differentially regulated
when vitamin e levels fluctuate so
having a balanced level of vitamin e in
our body
is absolutely essential for our immune
function
when we talk about immune function that
does not always mean that
augmented immune function or boosted
immune function
it talks about our immune homeostasis
that means a balanced
level right now
cell culture experiments has backed up
many data
they have elucidate the role of zinc
in immune modulation doctors often say
that zinc has immune boosting effects
and let me explain how
and experimentally it was proven
so t cells which are
crucial uh players in our immune system
they need to grow divide and proliferate
and it's so
important one of the cytokine
interleukin 2
is important for their division so
interleukin signaling which is a
autocrine signaling is crucial
for t cell proliferation now
scientists have done one experiment they
cultured diesel with high zinc
containing media
and losing containing media and later on
they checked
the level of il-2 which is a indicative
of how much a t cell might
proliferate and so so
they found that interleukin mrna levels
was were significantly high when the
zinc level was high
that means the chances are when zinc is
present
these t cells would proliferate more or
prepare themselves more for a combat
that means balance level of zinc
is crucial now you must be thinking that
what is the balance level now
before that let me tell you zinc
deficiency
can cause severe effects
zinc deficiency might have adverse
effect on
humeral immunity there could be thymic
atrophy
in absence of zinc that means thymus is
the hub for production of t
cells so t cells would be reduced in
that case
other than that
lymphopenia is one of the aspects of
this
zinc deficiency where lymphocyte numbers
would be reduced
let's talk about daily requirement if we
talk about a male
adult male we need 11 milligrams of
zinc daily where a female need eight
milligrams in normal state whereas 10 to
11 milligram
during pregnancy now daily requirement
of
zinc can be easily met with the help of
several foods
and here is a list of food which is
enriched
in zinc so 10 milligrams of
zinc can be obtained per oyster oyster
is one of the richest
source of zinc apart from oyster
if you eat beef steak chicken
you would get substantially high amount
of zinc per 100 grams of that meat
other than that tofu lentils mushroom
all of these have quite a lot of amount
of zinc
now while consuming these food you have
to always understand
that what amount of calorie you are in
taking
let's say just because beef steak has a
lot of zinc that doesn't mean you are
going to eat a lot of beef
beef stick because it would increase
your cholesterol
it would increase your omega-6 so it
would tip the balance again
so the overall story is you need to
balance your calorie intake and food
intake
based on these substances and based on
calorie
calculation now let's
talk about vitamin d which is another
proven immune boosting or
immune boosting substance so vitamin d
which is known as
125 dihydroxychola calciferol
that is important for
its immune modulatory function so let's
try to understand it in bit more details
when it comes to innate immune system
both macrophages
and dendritic cell which are the key
player of this system
they do have vitamin d receptors
that tells us that they are capable of
responding to vitamin d
now vitamin d receptors are found in
dendritic cell
and vitamin d receptors are nuclear
receptor which can
go to the nucleus upon vitamin d binding
and lead to many genetic changes
now question come which gene does it
change
and here is the key insight
so there are several cytokines which
leads to lot of inflammation in our body
right vitamin d reduce the
pro-inflammatory cytokines which causes
problems
you might be familiar that il-6 storm or
interleukin storm is a
key cause of death in covid patient now
vitamin d has a modulatory
role in the relative levels of that so
vitamin d
reduce the pro-inflammatory cytokines
whereas it
increase anti-inflammatory cytokines
such as il-10
and essentially vitamin d
balance the level of inflammation in our
body and which is
crucial now since we learn about all of
these
macro and micro nutrients their
importance in terms of
immunity we have to understand that
along with food sometimes sunlight
exposure is very important because it's
important for
vitamin d synthesis and here are some
list of vitamin d and rich food we can
get vitamin d
from cheese cereals butter
egg milk and fish
now the thing that we need to understand
as a third world country
is that how we can afford
these kind of food because many of the
food item that i have shown right now
which are enriched in nutrients but they
are
absolutely costly and how a middle class
man can afford all these costly food who
is struggling to
get some bowl of rice every day how can
he even think about these kind of
balance proportion of diet
and that is why consulting with a
nutritionist
and doctor is important just to know
about the alternative sources of these
nutrients if not possible
it is also feasible to take supplements
that might temporarily balance the level
of these macro and micro nutrients in
somebody's system and
it is crucial to get rid of all the bad
habits such as
alcoholism and cigarette smoking which
can
kill your immune system or which can
reduce
the efficiency of your immune system if
you want to know more about how
alcohol can reduce your immune system
let me know in the comment i'll make a
video on that
now if you like my video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe
thank you